(relaxing xylophone music)
- I'm a little bit scared,
because I know that
Australia has animals that could kill me.
- I've heard that kangaroos
are really strong,
and they like to box,
and I'm very scared to
meet an animal that knows how to box.
I feel like this is gonna
be an Alice in Wonderland
type experience, in which I'm gonna
go through the looking glass, and wind up
somewhere that I don't even think is real.
- I expect to lay on the ground and cuddle
with at least three kangaroos.
- This is real. This is really happening.
We've just taken the ferry, and now
we're about to go into
the sky to meet koalas.
(funky rock music)
- Oh my god!
- They're all just chillin'.
- [Girl] Holy shit,
literally just laying there.
- [Guy] What an amazing union of animals.
(upbeat rock music)
I think I've found my spirit animal.
I'm really into this echidna.
Hi, Mia.
- This is our baby quokka.
- [Guy] Their numbers are declining
because they're being hunted?
- [Zookeeper] Because they
were being hunted originally,
but now they're only
found on Rotness Isle,
and they once were found
throughout Australia.
- This is like, the perfect animal.
I can't believe somebody would actually
want to hunt this, this is like the most
adorable thing I've ever seen in my life.
This is bonkers.
Oh, hello.
(pleasant guitar music)
I can't believe you're real.
- It looks like a stuffed animal. Oh!
It's moving, oh my god!
- [Guy] Oh, hi!
- [Girl] It's so chill. It's
the chillest creature on earth.
- [Guy] It's like all
of the stuffed animals
from my childhood came alive.
- I kind of feel like I'm still dreaming,
like that didn't just happen.
- I feel really changed.
- I have a new dream job, and it's
to be an Australian zookeeper.
- A lot of animals, or even other places,
you only think of them through TV or
the Internet, or children's storybooks,
and to actually be able to experience it
was really, really special.
- It's like, I'm gonna tell my children
about this, someday, and they're
gonna be like, "No you didn't."
- [Guy] I still can't get over
that a quokka licked my cheek.
- [Girl] I think my favorite
was for sure the quokka,
because it's like a happy bunny rabbit.
- [Guy] To be honest, it's
gonna be hard to eat meat after this.
- I would 100% come back here, like,
I wanna come back in an hour.
- [Guy] They're absolutely
beautiful, amazing creatures.
Quokka is who you party with,
kangaroo is who you hang out with,
and the echidna is a person that's
a little bit too cool for you.